how did you two come into this you're  gonna plunder a few temples loot the  museum that's just a little historical  research  mighty  client is willing to part with a huge  sum of cash we acquire a certain object  they called it the wish-fulfilling jewel  that's going to be worth millions  hundreds of millions hang on a minute  easier said than done this is fake it's  a forgery you've been play honor among  thieves huh I'm the good businessman  you're a pirate you're gonna snatch that  treasure right out from under them they  get us all killed come on  you're in then what the hell and what  could possibly go wrong ps4 for the  players